[Musik]
herzlich willkommen hier
für mich wäre es das erste Mal dass ich
bei der Soldaten Wallfahrt dabei sein
darf es waren gestern beeindruckende
Erlebnisse begonnen vom Marsch vom
Einzug vom gemeinsamen das Erleben
dieser Internationalität und das Gefühl
auch das Zusammenhaltes auf der einen
Seite laut durchaus laut von den einen
oder anderen Nationen laut und bunt und
dann in der Gruppe angekommen wo die
Messe gehalten wird
das Spüren dessen uns wirklich geht dass
sich zu besinnen und gerade in Zeiten
wie diesen auch wohl zu finden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
dann das Zeltlager auch besuchen was
auch ganz wichtig ist die Möglichkeit zu
nutzen mit den Soldatinnen und mit den
Soldaten auch Gespräche zu führen und
auch über ihre über ihre Eindrücke eben
zu sprechen darauf freue ich mich auch
ganz besonders
[Musik]